third glass tonight put it on my tab we
drinking to remember forget giving a
[ __ ] won't get you a better tip highway
my whole family was killed in a car
accident
someone did horrific experiments on me I
know this super vigilante [ __ ] keeps
coming at me
do you know Captain America
I want to absorb alias investigations
you don't want me you just want to
eliminate the competition
I never take no for an answer how rapey
of you something happened behind these
doors I have 17 years of questions and
they are deep just knowing what was done
to you might help you we were made here
me and something else
the only way to find it is to open the
door wider
[Music]
the powers were side effect how many
others are there like me
let it go there is a killer you cannot
control I didn't ask for any of this
Jessica might not want a sidekick but
she needs one you're not super time keep
telling me who I talk to you
[Music]
what a face it makes me worse what are
you gonna do I don't know depends on if
I can get through this night without
losing my [ __ ] it takes a monster
to stop the monster
[Music]
what did they do to us like you stay
keep you inside hey everybody we got new
Jessica Jones footage to breakdown and
we finally got our first look at
kilgrave slow clap for kilgrave coming
back headspace kilgrave because
obviously he's still dead after season 1
so if you wondered why people were
seeing him walk around on set because
David Tennant was spotted on set while
they were filming he's just gonna be the
manifestation of all of Jessica's
self-doubt and all her self-loathing
just sort of slow clapping his way
through the season trying to get her to
doubt herself so he's not the main
antagonist but you could call him that
if you think that Jessica is her own
main antagonist but she's the person
who's doubting herself the most and
there's this whole running theme through
the trailer about her facing her past
and her demons there are a couple car
accidents that you see them keep
flashing back to there's one in present
day very clearly because you see her
wearing the leather jackets amidst the
wreckage here but you also hear her
talking about the original wreckage that
killed her parents and that led to her
being experimented on where she got her
powers so for the most part the IgH
corporation is sort of the MacGuffin of
the season the stuff that gave them
powers the other people they got
experimented on that woman sort of
explains what was happening we weren't
trying to give you superpowers we were
trying to bring you back to life which
may tie in to defenders with all the
Iron Fist mythology in the dragon bones
that the hand was using if you were sure
what was going on with that like they
had that black sludge but the key
component to bringing people that were
part of the hand back to life was
grinding up dragon essence so that's
where they were mining beneath the city
but I gh the corporation might have had
financial ties to the hand because to
make as many puns as possible the hand
had its fingers in everything possible
they may have been trying to make
synthetic replicas of what they were
doing with these dragon bones but when
it seems like they're doing is is even
you know though Jessica in her mind
space kilgrave are big antagonists it
does sound like there's an actual
monster that was also created by Eiji
because she says it takes a monster to
catch a monster jeryn hogarth said that
there's a monster out there that you
can't control so it sounds like what's
going on is that like a killer pops up
and through the course of her normal
investigations like she's resumed alias
investigations she's taking normal cases
through the course of one of those she
stumbles upon a killer that has ties to
IgH it's probably this person here
that's throwing the guard in this
hospital hallway with all the alarms
flashing because you see a corresponding
scene with Jessica in a hospital gown
that might be a flashback to when she
escaped from the lab that gave her
powers like she busts in here and it
looks like it's at present day like it's
all in disarray like the company doesn't
exist anymore she runs into this person
here she explains the experiments they
did on her and she says how many of us
are there out there how many other
people did you experiment on and they
don't answer the question literally but
like when you see this person throw it
and she says it takes a monster to kill
a monster someone's out there killing
people what if looking into my past
makes me worse it sounds like there's
gonna be that dichotomy where you have a
bunch of people that were experimented
on one of them wound up being Jessica in
through the defenders and her meeting
Luke Cage and all these other people
like daredevil she's found a better way
to deal with her past so her life has
taken a more positive direction but on
the other side of that you have another
person who was experimented on and given
powers by IgH in their life just went
down the [ __ ] so they turned into
more of a straight-up villain so through
the course of the season she might try
to help these people or this one other
person we don't know how many other
people got powers from IgH and maybe it
winds up going in a tragic way usually
the ending of Jessica Jones stories are
a kind of melancholy and hopeful at the
same time like everybody isn't gonna
wind up hugging each other at the end of
the story but usually you feel kind of
good about where they left things like
jessica is in a better place that when
she's started in this story as far as
other defenders crossing over I don't
know who's gonna pop up but I am
expecting some sort of daredevil minor
crossover because they both live in
Hell's Kitchen
even though daredevil Himself is down
for the count so just assume that when
this series picks up is after the events
of the defenders so pretty much
everybody still thinks that Matt's dead
I don't think anybody's gonna learn that
he's still alive till the beginning of
daredevil season 3 and that's probably
not going to premiere till the very end
of this year we don't have a firm
premiere date for daredevil season 3 yet
and Luke Cage sees
- will premiere before that but I love
that Captain America Easter egg do you
know Captain America so that's probably
her just on her normal rounds trying to
help regular people out the thing is is
that she actually does know Captain
America in the comics she's worked with
the Avengers in fact in the original
Bendis stories she was investigating
Captain America because it was around
the time Civil War was going down so she
wound up taking a lot of pictures of
Captain America himself so technically
yes she does but that's just them
winking at the comics and I don't you
know people wondering about infinity war
if this is happening in present day what
they'll probably do after infinity war
because it doesn't seem like the
defenders are gonna appear during that
look they just did that 10th anniversary
promo
none of the TV people were sitting in
those stands like this big picture is
just movie people the way they treated
the Avengers invasion during the first
series of all the different defenders is
just call it the incident so it'll
probably happen after infinity war is
that they'll do something similar
they'll call it an incident but remember
now that we have Doctor Strange with the
time gem he can actually literally turn
back time within a localized field so
that if there's a crazy damage around
the sanctum he can reverse that pretty
quickly and I just did that infinity war
promo video where they show you which
gems Thanos has by the end of the film
in the time gem is not one of them I'll
leave the video at the end of this but
they're just a number of different ways
that the Netflix series can reconcile
what happens in New York during infinity
war but aside from Easter eggs 99% sure
that none of the TV characters are going
to appear during infinity war but there
might be some Easter eggs because New
York is a big place there's a lot of
stuff going on there's a lot of dudes in
red running around so maybe they'll make
some jokes about the devil of Hell's
Kitchen when they're talking about
spider-man fun fact - there was a little
while in the comics where spider-man
wore Daredevils costume but they're
actually giving that storyline to Iron
Fist
during his season two because now that
Daredevils down for the count he's sort
of taken on his duty of protecting the
city although he's kind of wearing the
green jumpsuit so I think that when Iron
Fist is taking on Daredevils duties
protecting the city he will not wear the
actual daredevil costume but that's all
iron fist season 2 stuff maybe they'll
address it during Luke Cage season 2
because iron fist is going to be
crossing over so I'll link that video at
the end of this - but for the most part
the only other really big storyline
they're teasing in this is the idea of
Patsy Walker Hellcat becoming an actual
sidekick she's kicking that dudes ass in
the alleyway she says that Jessica
doesn't want a sidekick but she needs
one so we might actually get to see her
wear some sort of protective costume by
the time they get to Jessica Jones
season three but I'm not expecting her
to put on a hellcat looking costume
anytime soon you have to remember Melvin
Potter is still out there but he's
really like the daredevil connection so
if anybody's gonna get a new costume
from Melvin Potter on the other series
they're probably gonna get the hook-up
from daredevil but you can't really do
that till after daredevil season 3 when
everyone realizes that Matt didn't die
but again all the episodes for Jessica
Jones are dropping March 8th of course
I'll do videos just like I did for
season 1 season 2 leave all your
requests in the comments below be sure
to subscribe to get everything make sure
you click that Bell to turn alerts on so
you don't miss any of the videos and it
congratulations to the latest Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway winner Kevin Walden
please private message me so I can get
your contact details I have a new
Deadpool video that I'll post tomorrow
so I'll do new round of the giveaway
when I post that but click here for that
new Infinity Gauntlet promo and click
here for that Luke Cage season 2 Heroes
for Hire video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight